♪ ♪ ♪
- Ces apiculteurs du Yucatan
se sont regroupés pour améliorer
leur production de miel.
Leur coopérative, financée
par l'État, se consacre
à la production de reines
d'abeilles italiennes,
sans aucun produit chimique.
"Changer les reine améliore
la production et diminue
l'agressivité des abeilles.
Elles produisent plus de miel
et du miel de meilleure qualité
parce que les pays importateurs,
comme l'Allemagne, la Grande-
Bretagne, les États-Unis
tolèrent de moins en moins
les produits chimiques et
veulent de l'organique."esesesee
sont pas de gros consommateurs
de miel, mais ce sont de gros
producteurs et exportateurs.
Cinquième au monde avecune indue
dans la péninsule du Yucatan.
(bourdonnements)
Or, les petits prsssss
se plaignent. Ils sont 3000
dans la région et trouvent
que l'industrie ne valorise pas
assez leur miel.
L'entrepôt, tout neuf, est
presque prêt à recevoir le miel
des associés. Ce qu'ils veulentn
fort : équitable et biologique.
Sur 57 000 tonnes de miel
produits chaque année au
Mexique, 10 % seulement sont
biologiques. Et les clients
étrangers détectent de plus
en plus de traces d'OGM
et de pesticides dans
le miel mexicain.
"Les abeilles souffrent d'un
désordre organique. Elles ont
du mal à ingérer le nectar et
ensuite ."."."."."."
En cause, la déforestation.
Début décembre, la récolte
du soja se termine. Les fermiers
sont des mennonites originaires
du Manitoba. Ils avaient émigré
en 1917 pour fuir l'école
obligatoire. Le Mexique
les avait alors accueillis
dans l'état voisin du Chihuahua,
affligé de sécheresses
chroniques.
Il y a une dizaine d'années,
l'état de Campeche au Yucatan,
plus humide, leur a proposé
de bonnes terres à bon prix.
Mais il fallait déboiser
ce qu'ils ont fait massivement.
En dix ans, la péninsule
du Yucatan a perdu plus
de 80 000 hectares de forêt,
selon Global Forest Watch.
Plus de la moitié dans l'étateùt
multipliés les champs de maïs
et de soja. Depuis 2010,
la culture du soja est passée
de 7000 à 165 000 hectares,
selon les chiffres du ministère
de l'Agriculture.
Et 80 % de ces terres
appartiennent à des mennonites.
C'eututututututututé moderne
connectée par Internet à
la Bourse de Chicago. Seuls
les vêtements de ces femmes
et enfants trahissent leurs t t.
(espagnol)
En 2012, des apiculteurs mayas,
avec à leur tête cette femme,
Leydy Pech, qui élève des
abeilles mélipones sont partis
en guerre contre les cultures
OGM des grands agriculteurs.
Leurs abeilles mourraient
par millions. Les mennonites
ont viu u u u u u u u u doigt.
Les apiculteurs mayas ont gagné
leur bataille juridique contre
les OGM de Monsanto, devenuenen,
les OGM sont interdits,
mais il reste des doutes.
"Pas d'OGM chez nous",
affirme Cornelius Loewen.
"On a essayé les OGM sur
le maïs, mais ça n'a pas marché.
Par contre, le glyphosate,
impossible de s'en passer."
"Le glyphosate tue
les mauvaises herbes, mais avant
la semaille. Une fois le champ
semé, il n'en reste plus. Nous
ne sommes pas entièrement bio,
mais nous utilisons très peu
de produits chimiques."
Les ruches de la communauté en
forêt alentour des champs sont
en bonne santé.
Nous avons apporté un plan de
soja de Santa Rosa à l'agronome
"Ce soja n'est pas
transgénique, affirme-t-il.
Les mennonites travaillent biené
des semences disponibles sont
transgéniques parce qu'il n'y
en a pas assez de naturelles
c'est la faute du gouvernement
mexicain qui en a le contrôle."
Le sénateur Jorge Carlos
Ramírez Marin a basé toute
sa récente campagne électorale
sur le thème de la protection
des abeilles.d d d d d d d d d s
c'est la civilisation qui va
disparaître. Et la planète."
"Nos agriculteurs qui
déboisent pour produire
plus vont devoir dépenser
plus en pollinisation."
Les abeil
jusqu'à 75 % des plantes.
Les natives, comme la mélipone,
vont polliniser les espèces
natives de la forêt maya,
............
Le sénateur se donne comme
objectif de faire reconnaître
les particularités des miels g t
et surtout mettre un terme à
la déforestation de la péninsule
du Yucatan. Enfin, impliquer
strictement l'interdiction
des OGM et limiter l'usage
de pesticides.
♪ ♪